hello everybody and welcome back let's
play dead space 2 okay I just got over a
little bit about a rage episode I got a
little angry it's all good now cuz now I
got the world's ugliest suit all rusted
and dilapidated why would I even trust
this thing ah whatever it's fine
give me more inventory what do you guys
said that it also offers you get to keep
the inventory from super suit so I could
switch back but I like this it's got
character it was like me I leave
anything in this room look like it
I made my way through here and I killed
a big one right there
oh hello Caleb hello
oh those in the other log hello our node
what are you doing up there yeah I see
me waiting for you right up there Isaac
stop going crazy get a hold of yourself
the suit can't protect you from what's
inside your mind
ah huh Vince Vince uh [ __ ] around
with me
what hey Ruby found you oh hell yes
holy crap give me a Ruby not bad
sound good got plenty of that
[Music]
oh hey hello baby
the only other way through the
processing farm but it's not meant for
human traffic I think it thoroughly
I do baby it's ok straw he's gonna be ok
ahh I see a power node over there I want
it without it you gonna send me off to
my doom baby oh you so fine you're not
yeah not my type
Ross is not ok let's see y'all baby save
and then I gotta go fix something or go
the long way around
just how's that bench
ah
oh it's just machinery of course of
course
aah oh no got you so that spoken
ah
ah everywhere ah yeah yeah god damn it
I'll damn it damn it damn it I don't
have any help no not today
oh there we go got all of them
I lost the body I lost two bodies damn
it
javelin sends bodies away without giving
me ideas well there it is
give it not that not you either and he's
just over the corner yeah boy did I get
you
where is he oh I see a piece of them
pretty go come on it's awfully noisy in
here well I got six partners let's go
for my rig get some TK damage
connections I've been meaning to do that
for a while I need to be smarter about
using the telekinesis as opposed to
anything
I I wasted a lot of ammo the electricity
on the javelin gun isn't as great as I
imagined
of course it's so could be my zero-g
wait look at me go
I would expect a suit like this would
have like oh these are the thrusters oh
can I move okay set on they're gonna hit
it go have to wait it's ammo oh damn it
good man just push that with my legs
oh man
oh that way that's not
no I did not I did not see anything I
saw nothing
ah
hello
providing me with your location ah shut
up a hole the processing cycle on and
you end with it wait oh [ __ ] is she
working yes we have to be this one time
it does
did she betray me no I think what he
meant was
by turning off the power
you saw where the power was off an
obviously person
what I'm expecting her to
we're gonna
okay hi baby Frank boo-boos you hurt
now for other babies
well that's good
okay
of stasis oh okay I get to space
womp yeah I'll give it through dare yeah
I'm the best best there ever was what
what's that that baby after you yeah
womp my already out of ammo I'm not I
tried to reload you it was like nope not
having that oh what's that
every okay those are taken care of
give me your goodies dear goodies Ellie
can't you shut these things off no
somehow time and declare me dead in the
system now my clothes don't work
I need you I need you to follow the step
shut up who do you think you are me like
that whoosh mazes
I wonder how they imagined that stasis
works if I zap Tolkien it
ah they're coming at me oh yeah I'm less
impressed with be dabbling tonight
if the enemy's welcome lumped up real
tight I can see goes against those
little guys it could be useful but oh
there we go
I'll stick with it how's that oh my god
Oh
I can one-shot you
I totally can watch dis Oh what come on
show yourself huh what huh got ya
you know for being such a big guy who
lady yeah
how much of a danger one detonator shot
and not
okay you think there would be an easier
way to set those up I mean I'm sure the
designers who made that the engineers
and whatnot made that device did not
intend for it I'm coming to save the day
if I can kill tenzou jillion of those
things by myself you can take care of
you good thank you thank you lady I
heard something ah the charging thing
let me get it well there you are
[Music]
do you see where I put that fire note
here yep got it goodies oh that's good
me after this I thought I was gonna blow
myself up again oh yeah oh my ha ha no
thanks to twitchy here she's taken aback
by how handsome I looking for you ok
it's getting worse
what is step four who will be waiting
you know he's not gonna make it we gotta
keep moving as an industrial transport
upstairs one's the same spoke as the
commuter train but should get us to
government sector sure one of us will
have to deploy it from the gear house I
wonder who that'll be asking I stay here
and uh I try to get him on his feet
yeah wait good luck with that the store
around here
when I need it it's nice to be in the
same room as these people
hello baby are you yeah you come for you
I'll be back baby don't worry your night
is rusting armor see what that oh ho in
my way not like
all right who wants to mess with me hmm
Oh chapter nine look at that
huh hey whomp ah what the hell when you
come through you know oh there we go no
no shoot in it
well back
oh god I'm not gonna detonate her if I
was skilled with the dead Vader I
definitely have a starting
[Applause]
oh-oh-oh-oh
how many just you need lady is that lady
right aren't you
your lady it's hard to tell let me get a
look at no you're just gonna stay there
fine fine whatever
oh that's actually all the time I got to
visit thank you guys so much for
watching you know and as always I will
see you in the next part
bye bye